back up right now we did not awesome
your eyes util II back it up I'm Tracy
Oppenheimer freezin TV and today we're
talking with teri brassy in Tucson
Arizona he's a staff engineer at the
University of Arizona's lunar and
planetary lab teri thanks for having us
thank you for having me one of your
sites that you visit is the Kitt Peak
Observatory and along the route to
getting to the observatory there is an
in-country immigration checkpoint and
you've been stopped numerous times over
the years first can you talk about what
an in-country immigration checkpoint is
the Customs and Border Protection is
allowed to set up permanent immigration
checkpoints within a reasonable distance
of the border and a reasonable distance
of the border has been defined within
100 air miles of the actual border as
long as they're set up along Nexus
points for bordick traffic they have
permanent stations that sort of thing
what the US Supreme Court has never
ruled on is whether or not a internal
checkpoint that set up away from a nexus
point such as along a secondary road
that maybe parallels the actual border
but where most of the traffic is
domestic in nature whether or not those
types of checkpoints are considered
lawful and that's a type of checkpoint
that I go through describe your
experience start at the beginning when
you first got stopped my first
experience at any sort of checkpoint
whatsoever was allegedly a sobriety
checkpoint and even though they were
claiming that it was only a sobriety
checkpoint that I was being stopped at
it was very clear almost from the moment
I arrived at the checkpoint that they
were doing a far more expansive
operation when you see a large
complement of federal agents at a local
sobriety checkpoint you know that
there's something strange going on there
so when I came up to be processed there
I asked a stopping officer I said well
what type of checkpoint is this and he
said well it's a sobriety checkpoint I
said well if that's if it really if it's
a sobriety checkpoint then why is there
a u.s. customs agent and Border Patrol
agents operating with you on the front
line and he didn't like my my question
very much things quickly went downhill
and I found myself being dragged out of
my vehicle and handcuffed
off to the side of the road for asking
some questions and basically asserting
my rights while I was there I had a
detective at that checkpoint tell me
that they could tell that I hadn't been
drinking because I was talking very
coherently but I was also talking about
US Supreme Court cases in regards to you
know what the proper scope of these
checkpoints is supposed to be but he
said because this area is known for
smuggling both humans and drugs that
everyone was being compelled to identify
themselves before they were being
allowed to pass through so it was very
clear they were operating outside of the
reasonable boundaries of a sobriety
checkpoint so they charged me with two
criminal misdemeanors during that
encounter for what for disobeying the
orders of a law enforcement officer
directing traffic and for refusing to
provide identification after this
incident I put a camera on your car
you're trying to hold these officers
more accountable in the future how did
that play out I decided I would never
put myself in that situation again and
knowing that this area was an area where
I was more likely to run across more
checkpoints over the years I decided to
start carrying video cameras and audio
recording devices wouldn't they and to
this day I record every time I have an
encounter with enforcement agents along
that route i videotape that encounter
for the purposes of immigration I need
to ask you one punch
you can ask me whatever you want am I
being detained I had agents you know
basically telling me that it was illegal
to to videotape them that they that I
didn't have their permission to tape
them and that sort of thing and it took
you know repetitive action and whatnot
to make it clear to them that I didn't
need their I didn't need their
permission or their consent to video
record them while they were seizing me
in a lane of traffic along a public
highway
so could you estimate how many times
you've been pulled over I estimate that
I've been through the checkpoint roughly
300 to 350 times since January 2008 when
I first started videotaping my
encounters at the Border Patrol
checkpoint back in January 2008 within a
couple of months the Border Patrol Union
not the actual Border Patrol but the
Border Patrol Union attempted to get me
fired here at the University by writing
letters of complaint to the University
President and also wrote to the Arizona
State Legislature now and also wrote to
various local law enforcement agencies
claiming that I was violating law by
posting video and pictures of Border
Patrol agents online they're claiming
that there is an Arizona state law that
makes it a crime to post personally
identifiable information about a law
enforcement officer a federal agent
who's standing in the middle of a public
highway wearing a public uniform
collecting a public paycheck while
seizing the public absent reasonable
suspicion has no expectation of privacy
and this is one thing that I really like
to remind folks of that the government
thinks that we don't have any right to
privacy whatsoever but that's a
double-edged sword
so once they start claiming that once
you're in public you have no right to
privacy that also goes for the agents
that we pay with our tax dollars in a
big part it's the Department of Homeland
Security and they're saying I mean their
purpose is to protect us from external
threats and improve our security and and
why do you think this is crossing the
line well first I think is a fault
that that's a false premise that a lot
of people operate under that this is for
the security of the nation it really
isn't
the numbers the raw numbers coming out
of the government itself shows that this
is not increasing our security in fact
it's making us less secure it's just
feeding a empire-building its feeding
its feeding agency budgets and and job
security for various law enforcement
agencies other than these checkpoints
being a nuisance
why do you think they inhibit your
personal freedom after young children
and I don't want them growing up in a
country where they can be just
arbitrarily seized by some random
government agent and presumed to be
guilty of something and then be forced
to you know just prove their innocence
on demand that's not what this country
is about it's not what it was founded on
and it shouldn't be tolerated by free
people and this is that's exactly what
the whole purpose of a checkpoint is it
presumes your guilt and it means that
you prove your innocence thank you so
much for your time Terry that was very
very informative Friesen TV I'm Tracie
Oppenheimer